bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour suivre les débats
dans l'hémicycle sur la transition
énergétique
les sénateurs s'attaque aujourd'hui au
coeur du texte l'article 1er qui fixe
les grands objectifs énergétiques de la
france avec un point d'achoppement
majeur le nucléaire d'un côté vous avez
le gouvernement qui veut ramener la part
du nucléaire dans le mix énergétique de
75 à 50% d'ici 2025 c'est d'ailleurs une
promesse de françois hollande
de l'autre les sénateurs de la majorité
qui juge cet objectif irréaliste
ils sont d'accord pour baisser la part
du nucléaire mais sans objectifs
chiffrés vous allez le voir ça va être
l'un des grands bras de fer de ce texte
tout de suite direction la séance pour
le débat oui madame la présidente madame
le ministre mes chers collègues
à cet instant le l'amendement de notre
collègue gremillet est soumis au débat
je voudrais le défendre tout en
comprenant le travail diplomatique
judicieux pertinent à binh et maîtrisé
de notre rapporteur
alors ça c'est vrai rapporteur ses
forces et apportera peas et je les dis
s'efforce de concilier les points de vue
mais je trouve que l'amendement daniel
grenier a l'immense mérite de poser une
question de principe
madame le ministre pourquoi croyez vous
que les consommateurs consomme-t-il de
l'énergie eh bien je vais peut-être
surprendre de sedan tech
mais ce n'est pas par perversité
ce n'est pas par souci de dégrader
l'environnement
ce n'est pas pour le plaisir de gaver
des émirs de revenus
substantielle mais c'est simplement
parce qu'ils en ont d'une part l'absolue
nécessité et que d'autre part dans une
économie de marché
des millions de décision assumée chaque
jour par des consommateurs privés ou
publics familiaux ou entrepreneuriaux
les conduisent dans un environnement
économique déterminée à choisir la
solution la plus rationnelle
j'écoutais madame jouanno à l'instant et
elle nous parle de l'ademe je comprends
très bien le volontarisme du
gouvernement
il ya quand même un moment on peut se
demander si l'économie de subventions
qui tord les prix et qui nie les
réalités économiques peut être
indéfiniment supporté par notre pays la
perspective de diminuer de 50% la
consommation énergétique de notre pays
c'est une décision idéologique elle ne
correspond à aucune démarche rationnelle
à aucune analyse prospective
elle correspond simplement à l'idée
qu'on pourrait faire différemment que la
france serait exemplaire et
accessoirement parce que la france n'est
pas soumis à élection que le
gouvernement lui sera exemplaire au sein
de sa majorité et toutes ses composantes
de sa majorité
c'est pas du tout le cas la consommation
obéit à des lois qui sont des lois
économiques qui s'impose au monde entier
par exemple en effet depuis 2008 nous
avons un plafonnement de la consommation
électrique
mais lorsque l'on rentre dans le détail
de ce plafonnement
on s'aperçoit que ce plafonnement était
là c'est daniel gremillet à raison liée
à la très forte diminution de
consommation d'industrie majeur dans
notre pays qui ont diminué leurs
activités et qui ont par conséquent
diminuer leur consommation électrique
c'est un premier point vous avez ensuite
en effet la sphère du logement mais il
ya une question qui devrait quand même
posé un jour si l'économie
d'énergie consommée dans le bâtiment et
rentable pourquoi diable faut-il la
supporter à grands coups deux
subventions et d' avantages fiscaux
c'est parce qu'en réalité chaque
consommateur nous avez donné un exemple
très spectaculaire madame le ministre
il mériterait d'être regardé dans son
ensemble mais il y à 30 millions de
logements en france nous en construisons
moins de 300 milles actuellement est il
raisonnable chaire chantal jouanno de
penser qu'il y aura cinq cent mille
ruses rénovation actuellement la réponse
est non la réponse est non parce que
dans la priorité du pouvoir d'achat des
familles
il n'est pas pensable qu'elles
investissent dans un logement français
qui est aujourd'hui le logement le plus
cher en europe ce qui est
invraisemblable
alors que nous avons le territoire le
plus vaste et nous devrions avoir le
foncier le plus léger il n'est pas
certain que la priorité des familles
sera de course de consacrer sauf s'il y
sera obligé par la règlement a mobilisé
des sommes importantes en termes
d'économie d'énergie parce qu'elles font
elles mêmes l'arbitrage entre la dépense
qu'il faut pour économiser quelque chose
et le retour sur investissement vous
avez dit madame le ministre et je
terminerai qu'il y à des économies
d'énergie dans l'industrie mais c'est
évident c'est évident il y a de la
chaleur qui part dans tout les fumées du
sinn simplement la rentabilité des
investissements n'est pas à la hauteur
en train une société idéale et une
société que l'on peut s'offrir il y à un
moment il faut laisser respirer
l'économie et laisser la liberté aux
décisionnaires c'est la raison pour
laquelle sur le plan des principes je
défends l'amendement de mon collègue
daniel dremière je vous remercie alors
monsieur delattre vous voulez parler oui
c'est ça ou de prendre la parole je vous
en prie je meurs si madame la présidente
chers collègues osé écrire aux as même
article que l'on va réduire de 30% la
consommation des énergies fossiles en
2030 par rapport à 2012 et réduire en
même temps la part du
à la production d'écrits la production
d'électricité à 50% à l'horizon 2025
alors qu'on est aujourd'hui à 75 %
relève plus mes chers collègues de la
philosophie que des réalités économiques
de notre pays aujourd'hui l'alternative
sérieuse en termes de masse aux énergies
fossiles
c'est le nucléaire il faut bien sûr
encourager toutes les formes d'énergies
renouvelables les fixer des objectifs
dans la loi qui ne sont en réalité que
les termes d'un accord politique ne peut
que conduire à une terrible impasse pour
notre compétitivité pour nos emplois
pour l'avenir de toute une génération
on n'arrivera pas à supprimer non plus
parce qu'en fait la réalité quand on
fait le calcul il nous faudrait
supprimer deux centrales nucléaires par
an et je suis très surpris de constater
que personne ne parle du coût des
démantèlements ça coûte cher de des mots
clés il y avait même des amortissements
qui a été prévu et ses investissements
ont été au fil du temps on va dire
confisqué il serait plus sérieux il
serait plus sérieux car il nous faut du
temps d'envisager la modélisation la
remise à niveau des centrales et
investir surtout dans la nouvelle
génération et j'avais cru que c'était un
des objectifs de madame la ministre je
dirais aussi que nous sommes tous ici
élus locaux nous connaissons l'étendue
des dégâts du parc pas loin 30 millions
de logements sont en difficulté point de
vue la consommation énergétique
il faudra donc du temps et encore plus
de moyens
en plus des incantations du possible et
à l'avènement des quartiers intelligent
parce que en fait c'est pas pour demain
les quartiers intelligent enfin le
nucléaire est une des activités
potentiellement exportatrices pour notre
pays
mais cette défiance permanente nous
organisons sur le tard la france ne peut
qu'handicapé la crédibilité de la
filière qui fut d'excellence j'ai eu
l'occasion de sa genèse le visiter daya
bay en chine la première centrale
nucléaire française qui fut un vrai
succès alors c'est bien dommage dans le
contexte actuel la situation économique
industriel de notre pays d'abandonner
parce qu'en fait dès lors que sur son
propre territoire vous abandonner l'idée
même d''excellents' de la filière
vouloir exporter ce sera très compliqué
en plus contrairement à ce qu'on entend
le mix en europe
il inclut du nucléaire il y à des pays
ils sont dépourvus aujourd'hui de
nucléaire et qui envisage de construire
notamment le long du danube en tchéquie
en hongrie est naturellement l'actualité
oui le mx 6 1 gilles inclut le les
inclure l'énergie nucléaire parce qu'ils
sont à côté eu des mines de charbon et
de ligne exploité par l'allemagne
ils en subissent quotidiennement les
inconvénients c'est une réalité
le déni de réalité ne devrait pas
devrait nous inspirer aujourd'hui quand
on a ces situations alors pour toutes
ces raisons je pense que l'article pas
puisqu'on est dans les explications de
vote
à titre personnel naturellement je
voudrais compte les dispositions de cet
article qui ne correspond pas à une
réalité industrielle d'un pays mais qui
correspond à un accord politique a été
conclu il ya quelques années et tout le
monde se souvient de 3,4 centrale ne
savait plus ce n'était pas sérieux hier
et ce n'est pas encore servi aujourd'hui
bien
alors monsieur de là tout à fait
l'explication son article nous en sommes
pour l'instant aux amendements mais
s'est fait comme ça c'est fait je vais
donner la parole à monsieur bourquin
l'ama et et après aller non non après
chaque collègue j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure mon collègue remiller dix ans la
production industrielle a baissé et
vouloir faire baisser la consommation
d'énergie peut participer à la
désindustrialisation
j'ai envie de lui dire que la
désindustrialisation du pays a commencé
il ya 30 ans avec l'énergie la moins
chère d'europe
si si effectivement le coût de l'énergie
il faut défendre un coût de l'énergie
bas était l'unique cause la
désindustrialisation
on aurait remédié très vite à cette
désindustrialisation la
désindustrialisation les venues d'une
idéologie l'idéologie post industrielle
où on nous disait qu'il ne fallait plus
d' usine et il nous fallait des services
à la place et c'est ça la cause et donc
je pense que il faut prendre conscience
ici il nous faut prendre conscience ici
qu'une entreprise compétitif n'est pas
une entreprise énergivores on a visité
avec le premier ministre il ya quelques
jours les rénovations d'ateliers il ya
deux choses pour être pour voir de la
compétitivité
bien sûr la robotique mais deuxième
chose les économies d'énergie qui sont
omniprésentes y compris dans la
réflexion des industriels et deuxième
chose
troisième chose le changement climatique
ne le voyez pas uniquement comme un
boulet à traîner
voyez le au contraire comme une chance
pour la france
une chance pour notre industrie pour
créer de nouveaux emplois
il y en a par exemple il y en a par
exemple dans les énergies renouvelables
il y en a aussi dans des techniques de
fabrication qui nous permettent
aujourd'hui d'avoir des produits presque
100% recyclable et avec des économies
d'énergie un importante
nous sommes au 21ème siècle essayons de
mettre en place
l'économie du xxième siècle avec y
compris les énergies du 21ème siècle le
nucléaire fait partie du mixte il faut
le défendre à hauteur on disait de 50%
ce dans un objectif mais il doit y avoir
aussi d'autres énergies et vous verrez
par exemple que la question de
l'hydrogène si on règle le transport et
le stockage sera mais vous le savez très
bien
il faut que notre pays à ce niveau là l
europe soit à la pointe de la recherche
pour que nous ayons les brevets sur ses
nouvelles énergies
donc je ne ne prenons pas cette question
comme un boulet à traîner
on va accueillir la conférence mondiale
du changement climatique
vous savez vous savez qu'aujourd'hui
cette conférence mondiale sur le
changement climatique doit doit nous
inciter à prendre justement pour des
raisons économiques et industriels la
tête de peloton de tête de la lutte
contre le changement climatique et avec
une volonté mais qui doit est
omniprésente c'est celle d'avoir les
industries de demain les industries de
demain c'était start up qui vend des
panneaux solaires de nouvelle génération
au japon et qui fait un tabac au japon
et c'est une start up française une
autre start-up qui étaient devant nous
et qui nous qui nous montrait il y a
quelques mois qu'avec des halles qu'on
arrive à faire maintenant des carburants
de nouvelle génération qui nous
donneront à la fois à la fois beaucoup
de productivité si nous savons le faire
mais surtout chez les carburants de
demain laissons vers les possibles et ne
restons pas sur des vieux réflexes
sinon nous allons être à la traîne du
développement industriel est à la traîne
à la traîne de la question du changement
climatique alors tout à l'heure un de
mes collègues disait faites attention
comment on est dans une situation
économique difficile la production
industrielle a montré un regain
certes ce regard est fragile
mais si nous voulons avoir une
production industrielle c'est aussi avec
de nouvelles industries et les énergies
renouvelables les énergies renouvelables
et les économies d'énergie seront au
coeur de cette nouvelle croissance en
quelque sorte
il faut trouver une nouvelle croissance
et une croissance durable et c'est comme
ça que la france justement
réindustraliser sera son économie et ça
c'est un challenge qui est devant nous
est-ce qu'on le prend ce challenge est
ce qu'on se dit on peut on peut le faire
est-ce qu'on a la volonté de le faire et
si on a la volonté
mais vous savez très bien qu'on y
arrivera
s'il ne se bouffe qu'à la parole et à
madame des ego merci madame président
moi j'ai bien écouté
madame le ministre et j'ai même entendu
quelques par son enthousiasme sur ces
questions je dis clairement mais enfin
mes chers collègues
moi je veux attirer votre attention sur
le fait que tout ça c'est extrêmement
théorique c'est de la théorie pure c'est
quoi au fond poursuivre un objectif de
réduction de la consommation énergétique
finale c'est quoi d'abord quelle est la
sanction si on le fait pas bien sûr on
sera tous leurs 2005 secondes pour le
voir évidemment bon mais quelques c'est
quoi la sanction c'est quoi ces
dispositions
c'est quoi ces dispositions législatives
qui consiste à mettre des trucs en place
et où il ya aucune sanction
vous vous posez pas des questions
là-dessus moi je vais vous dire je crois
que c'est des bonnes intentions
c'est des bons sentiments selon
l'idéologie qui est la nôtre et ça
correspond à ce que j'ai dit
cette nuit au moment de d2 de l'article
1 et des prises de parole c'est des bons
sentiments c'est tout cdc les bonnes
intentions selon l'idéologie qui est la
nôtre c'est pas autre chose et je vais
mettre un peu plus sévère c'est de la
communication
voilà même le ministre vous êtes dans de
la com vous êtes même le champion de la
communication c'est très fort là dessus
mais objectivement comme l'a dit gérard
longuet la consommation énergétique ne
s'est pas une résultante c'est d'abord
une
tu économique justement c'est pas un
objectif qu'on pouvait calé comme ça
quand vous annoncez pitou va suivre pas
du tout d'abord vous demandez jamais à
quel prix c'est moi je suis bon la
commission des finances
la question que je me pose constamment
dans cet article heures quel est le coot
j'aimerais vous entendre le vous poser
cette question
en tout cas c'est de la communication et
je vous redis et pourquoi sa
communication
parce que c'est une résultante ça
dépendra de l'engouement sera comme l'a
dit gérard longuet sur notre économie
mais c'est pas d'abord on décide que la
consommation est à tel niveau mais ça
tient pas debout
vous l'avez jamais fait d'économie c'est
pas possible madame lienemann vous avez
la parole je crois qu'avec monsieur
longuet madame des ego nous avons un
désaccord de mode d'intervention de
vision de l'avenir
quand vous décrivez la réalité telle que
vous la voyez c'est la main invisible du
marché c'est-à-dire chaque comportement
individuel va faire l'intérêt général
ben figurez vous monsieur longuet le
général de gaulle doit se retourner dans
sa tombe
parce que toutes les grandes politiques
publiques
vous avez raison si on laisse faire le
marché
si on ne prend aucune mesure public si
on n'a aucun engagement collectif nous
ne réduirons pas la consommation
énergétique et nous ne réduirons pas les
gaz à effet de serre et donc il faut
prendre des mesures qui oriente le
marché qui forment des politiques
publiques et qui pensent l'avenir avec
des objectifs qui mobilise elle public
elle privée c'est ça qui est proposé est
le gouvernement raison de proposer les
20%
parce que si dès à présent nous
commençons pas à faire des mutations
technologiques indispensables si nous ne
faisons pas dans les arbitrages
d'investissements notamment dans la
construction des efforts en direction
des technologies porteuses économies
d'énergie à long terme on perdra
compétitivité et on n'arrivera pas à
atteindre ses objectifs
et je vais vous dire monsieur l'organe
du point de vue économique que nous
avons intérêt à le faire quand j'étais
ministre du logement
j'ai proposé qu'on fasse des normes sur
la qualité du verre à faible émissivité
il vous a pas échappé que ceux qui ont
inventé le faire le verre à faible
émissivité c'était saint gobain saint
gobain avait à l'époque une grande
entreprise en france et dans votre
région
elle en avait une en allemagne pour
mille raisons de coût de je-ne-sais-quoi
qu'il fallait laisser faire le marché
on n'a pas voulu mettre des impôts
imposés les faire à faible émissivité
bilan des courses tous les emplois créés
par saint gobain pour les verts à faible
émissivité c'est en allemagne et dans le
nord de l'europe est maintenant il va
falloir qu'on achète du verre venant de
ces pays parce que nous n'avons pas à
temps accompagner les mutations
technologiques
deuxième sujet économique quand vous
faites les analyses global de
l'investissement dans l'immobilier
il ya à la fois l'investissement sur le
foncier
l investissement sur la bâtie or que
vous faites là line l'aller la
comparaison entre les pays qui ont fait
de gros investissements sur la qualité
du bâti notamment pour économiser
l'énergie
ils ont eu moins de spéculation sur le
foncier
parce que globalement quand vous avez
des sommes dans le marché pour vendre un
logement
si vous investissez sur le foncier vous
n'avez plus d'argent sur le bâti et que
nous on essaie d'orienter à ce que
l'investissement soit pas dans la rente
foncière mais bien sur le bâti parce
qu'il a productif productif d'emplois
productifs d'économie productive de
filières industrielles
alors oui cet objectif de 20% aérienne
est malade de ses coûts 20 % d'où ça
vient combien ça coûte
c'est la même chose que le plan climat
énergie au niveau européen
ce sont des objectifs qu'on se fixe en
commun qu'ils sont capables de mobiliser
la société et qui sont en elles-mêmes
parce qu'ils sont des objectifs partagés
porter d'arbitrage et non pas des
chiffres qui ne font que coûte et mais
il porte aussi et notamment tva de
grosses recettes
à venir pour l'état messieurs grémy et
vous avez la parole
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre
chers collègues je pense que ce point
est un point qui devrait nous rassembler
nous rassemble est pourquoi le débat il
n'est pas sûr la part des 50% de la vie
de du logement du déplacement de la
consommation au niveau des ménages
le débat il est sur les niveaux
industriels et la part industrielle et
je vais dire à notre collègue martial
bourquin soit il m'a pas entendu soit y
était distrait mais les chiffres que
j'ai donné j'ai eu le courage des
données depuis les années soixante
quinze que ça soit au niveau de l'emploi
du industrielle que ça soit niveau la
production énergétique que ça soit sur
la part industrielle dans le pib
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
sur ces 50 % personne ici qu'on soit du
milieu rural eu mes yeux robin ne peut
dire quelle que soit la région d'où on
vient
que nous n'avons pas besoin de retrouver
des emplois industriels
nous ne régleront pas le problème du
chômage d'autres pays si nous ne
retrouvons pas des emplois industriels
nous ne garderons pas le modèle social
dans notre pays si nous ne créons pas
des richesses je ne suis pas s'il vous
plaît je vous ai écouté je vous ai
écoutés je veux simplement dire qu'il ne
faut pas mentir mentir sur quoi on a
tous cette même ambition de retrouver de
l'emploi s'étant cet emploi qui va créer
des richesses qui me permettra
effectivement de garder ce modèle ce que
j'ai expliqué dans cet amendement c'est
quoi c'est d'expliquer que la base de
2012 n'est pas bonne elle n'est pas
bonne parce qu'on n'est pas dans la même
situation que d'autres pays parce qu'on
a effectivement perdu beaucoup trop
d'emplois industriels
et je suis d'accord avec là encore on
notre collègue martial bourquin
j'ai pas peur nous n'avons pas peur
c'est pas un boulet et je partage de
propos de madame la ministre
effectivement la transition énergétique
c'est une opportunité il mais ayons
l'honnêteté de reconnaître si on veut
partager horizon 2050 et g en coupe a
parlé des deux milliards d'êtres humains
en plus sur la planète
j'espère quand même que la france aura
l'ambition d'imaginer qu'elle pourra en
accueillir
j'espère imaginez que la france aura
l'ambition d'avoir aussi des parts de
marché dans cette nouvelle univers de
population horizon 2050
c'est ça le sens et le problème le
problème c'est l'amalgamme entre
l'ambition partagée sur les 50%
on se retrouverait tous et la
considération de la part économique et
notamment de la part industrielle et je
peux vous dire il n'ya pas un industriel
en france et je reprends le propos de
gérard longuet le premier euro économisé
contre y compris en air en efficacité
énergétique
mais il a la conquête en permanence
chaque fois qu'il fait un budget c'est
son souci premier
parce qu'il sait que c'est son prix de
revient derrière qui en découlent c'est
pour ça que je comprends pas qu'on se
déchire on devrait se retrouver et je
veux dire on conclure mon propos
on a besoin de se rassembler jeudi à
notre rapporteur a dit cela ce la
proposition qu'il nous fait
effectivement c'est de dire il ya un
objectif
le débat que nous avons eu dire
l'objectif y va être différent en
fonction des enjeux et des
problématiques
effectivement le 50% sur la partie
industrielle y est pas tenable
parce que s'il est dans la perspective
de 2050
ça veut dire que nous serons dans la
décroissance donc c'est pas possible si
on veut retrouver un emploi si on veut
garder notre modèle social
mais la sagesse et c'est pour ça que je
vais retirer mon amendement au bénéfice
de sa rédaction
puisqu'il a la sagesse de dire
clairement de nous dire clairement
effectivement c'est un objectif à 2050
pour ma part j'aurais pas mis 50 % pour
la partie industrielle
mais il la sagesse de dire et de dire
honnêtement tout en préservant la
compétitivité le développement du
secteur industriel
donc je retire mon amour je vous
remercie monsieur grémine et je vais
donc passer au vote
alors le premier amendement nous allons
voter c'est le 686 rectifié bis avec
deux amendements
deux amendements deux avis pardon
défavorable madame des esgaulx vous le
maintenez s'est régalé nous arrivons
donc au 715 qui a été défendu par
monsieur donc tech qui a aussi deux avis
défavorables
retirez vous aviez retirer le premier
pas le deuxième mais vous retirer celui
ci aussi très bien donc il reste
l'amendement 894 du gouvernement j'ai
été saisi d'un d'une demande pardon de
scrutin public par le groupe ump sur
l'amendement 894 je vous rappelle que
l'avis de la commission est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin sera ouvert
dans quelques instants
voici le résultat du scrutin numéro 95
sont des moments numéro 894 nombre de
votants 309 nombre de suffrages exprimés
280 pour l'adoption 131 contre 149
le sénat n'a pas adopté j'informe le
sénat que la commission de la culture
m'a fait connaître qu'elle a procédé à
la désignation des candidats qu'elle
présente à la commission mixte paritaire
chargée de proposer un texte sur les
dispositions restant en discussion de la
proposition de loi portant diverses
dispositions tendant à la modernisation
du secteur de la presse
cette liste a été publiée et la
nomination des membres de cette
commission mixte paritaire aura lieu
conformément à l'article 12 du règlement
je rappelle que monsieur le premier
ministre a demandé au sénat de bien
vouloir procéder à la désignation de
sénateurs appelés à siéger au comité de
surveillance de la caisse
d'amortissement de la dette sociale la
commission des affaires sociales a fait
connaître qu'elle propose la candidature
de monsieur jean-noël cardoux cette
candidature a été publié sera ratifié
conformément à l'article 9 du règlement
s'il n'y a pas d'opposition à
l'expiration du délai d'une heure nous
passons à l'article maintenant 938 un
monsieur paul y est à l'amendement 938
pardon messieurs poniatowski à la parole
cet amendement madame la présidente a
pour but de clarifier l'objectif de
réduction des énergies fossiles
initialement défini en énergie finale
puis en énergie primaire pour retiendra
notion de consommation totale qui permet
de viser à la fois et sans risque de
confusion
madame la ministre les consommations
finales et les consommations
intermédiaires
merci madame la ministre votre avis
favorable je vais mettre aux voix
le ch est longue et je vous en prie oui
merci madame la présidente madame le
ministre mes chers collègues le seul à
porter j'ai envie de voter votre
amendement mais je voudrais une
précision dans la consommation s'agit-il
de la consommation nationale intérieur
ou du solde d'accord de la production
totale considérez-vous par exemple
qu'une exportations d'énergie dans un
pays voisin constitue une consommation
nationale ou pas ma question n'est pas
complètement désintéressé complètement
neutre il faut savoir que sur la
production électrique française qui est
de l'ordre de m
l'ordre de 500 térawattheures annuel
nous avons une cinquantaine de tera watt
heure qui constitue un solde positif
d'exportation d'électricité alors joué à
savoir si dans l'esprit du gouvernement
et l'esprit du rapporteur
quand on limite la production d'énergie
est ce qu'on déclare également qu'on
décide de limiter le solde positif
d'exportation d'énergie
monsieur le rapporteur il s'agit bien
sûr cher gérard longuet de la
consommation nationale
point barre donc on peut vendre très
bien pas d'autres prises de paroles jeu
mais on voit l'amendement 938 de la
commission présentée par monsieur
poniatowski avec un avis favorable du
gouvernement
quai pour qui et contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement est adopté l'amendement 585
rectifié madame la mûre
oui madame la présidente il s'agit là d'
avoir des objectifs plus réalistes c'est
à dire de porter la part des énergies
renouvelables à 20% au lieu de 23 en
2020 et à 27 au lieu de 32 en 2030
c'est également une manière de suivre
les recommandations de l'union
européenne dames monsieur le rapporteur
alors maintenant la présidente oh oui
chère isabelle j'étais un peu gêné par
cet amendement parce qu'il le visent que
on est bien d'accord
le thermique et l'hydro en prenant des
chiffres qui correspondent à des
chiffres qui pourraient inclure non
seulement le thermique et l'hydro mais
d'autres énergies renouvelables c'est
pour ça que j'ai comme je l'avais dit en
commission
j'ai recherché d'où pouvaient provenir
notamment ceux 27 % en 2030
madame la ministre j'ai dit au moment où
c'était en commission peut être
arriverez vous à m'éclairer mais j'ai
peur qu'il ya eu confusion entre
thermique hydraulique avec cet objectif
intermédiaire madame la ministre dit le
rapporteur sur cet amendement avis
défavorable
très bien quelle qu'elle soit de prendre
la parole
madame la mûre c'est à dire qu'en
réalité je n'ai pas obtenu les
explications ni du rapporteur ni de
madame la ministre dans mon objectif
c'était d'être un peu plus réaliste
justement et de suivre les
recommandations de l'union européenne en
la matière
ça veut dire que vous maintenez votre
amendement c'est ça madame line la hat a
donc laissé le rapporteur c'est
justement dans les chiffres de l'union
européenne que je n'ai pas retrouvé ces
chiffres c'est pour ça que j'étais
embarrassée et c'est la raison pour
laquelle en définitive en commission n'a
préféré conserver les objectifs du texte
initial qui concerne toutes les énergies
renouvelables en les déclinant par
grands secteurs et en leur adjoignant un
objectif de 10% de gazole ouvrables en
on s'est simplifié la tâche lien donc
j'y souscris et je retire mon amendement
merci très bien cet amendement faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune le 309
recchi chez tout d'abord avec monsieur
requis merci à la présidente annie déjà
collègues
le projet droits de transit énergétique
et fixe comme objectifs de la politique
énergétique française
outre le nécessaire développement dr
giroux a bloqué le temps favorable
la réduction de la part de l'énergie
nucléaire dans le mix énergétique
français de 50 de grosses sommes c'est
angers qui pourrait traduire par sa
peinture de plusieurs centaines
plusieurs centrales nucléaires
c'est qu'à part est totalement
irréaliste la fia nucléaire qui
représente un des fleurons d'un outil
française est un gisement non
négligeable d'emploi garantit
l'indépendance et qui la france et
contribue ainsi à assurer la sécurité de
l'approvisionnement en énergie de la
france objectif visé article anja 5
d'articles premier par ailleurs quoi
qu'en dise le coût du nucléaire demeure
compétitif par rapport à celui des
énergies renouvelables grâce à un parc
légèrement amortie
or le prix de l'énergie est un élément
de tampy centrale que la facture
énergétique de la france s'élève à
environ 7 2 milliards d'euros pam
nucléaire permet ainsi de produire de
l'électricité à des prix relativement
bas pays constitue un atout majeur à la
fois
pour lutter contre la présence de la
précarité énergétique est ainsi que vous
préserver la compétitivité de nos
entreprises au sein les laïcs et clercs
présente comme un avantage non
négligeable d'être énergies décarbonées
permettait à la france de respecter ses
engagements en matière de pollution
atmosphérique
aussi plutôt que d'envisager de réduire
l'uqtr il commanderait d'encourager
l'innovation dans cette filière afin de
développer des systèmes de nouvelle
génération qui permet une meilleure
utilisation de la ressource intérieur en
uranium et qui respecte des objectifs de
sûreté nucléaire et le moment durable
grâce à une meilleure gestion des
déchets à durée de vie longue dont nous
proposons de nous de supprimer donc
c'est à cet allié à 28 merci alors le
586 rectifié madame la mûre
oui madame la présidente alors cet
amendement propose vient de réduire la
part du nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité à 50% mais cela à
l'horizon de la fin du siècle et c'est
pour suivre la recommandation de
l'office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques
qui a jugé qu'il fallait rééquilibrer la
production d'électricité en tendant vers
50 % d'ici la fin du siècle
en introduisant des énergies
renouvelables électrique couplé à des
moyens de stockage direct au fur et à
mesure de leur maturité technologique et
économique 717 monsieur dantec
on aura tout à l'heure à un amendement
sur le fait qu'on fasse preuve de
souplesse sur les choix énergétiques
pour l'est pour les îles non connectés
de moins de 2000 habitants
cela concerne notamment l'île de sein en
fait peut-être qu'il faudra étendre
l'amendement à un territoire d'un peu
plus de 60 millions d'habitants
puisque le débat nous avons actuellement
c'est un débat qui consiste à toujours
considéré que la france est en dehors du
monde donc c'est peut-être le moment il
2,5 il faut qu'on retravaille pour qu'il
s'applique à l'ensemble du territoire
français je crois qu'à un moment il va
falloir quand même qu'on arrête des
dettes dans dans quelque chose qui qui
est un peu hors sol qui est que le monde
aujourd'hui développe à marche forcée
les énergies renouvelables c'est le
chiffre que j'ai pu donner hier soir qui
est un chiffre de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie environ
d'ici 2020 1200 milliards
d'investissements dans le renouvelable
dans le monde
dans la même période l'investissement
sur le nucléaire sera à la louche et je
suis plutôt dans une estimation haute de
l'ordre de 120 milliards si la france
n'a pas une industrie extrêmement forte
sur le renouvelable
nous sommes marginalisés et quand je dis
marginalisés pour reprendre le débat
qu'on avait tout à l'heure sur
l'industrie ça veut bien dire que les
dizaines de milliers de créations
d'emplois qui sont sur le renouvelable
se créeront ailleurs dans le monde et
science qui est en train de se passer et
compris les décisions totalement
irresponsable pris sous le gouvernement
sarkozy de remise en cause du cadre
économique du photovoltaïque
ça a été des dizaines de milliers
d'emplois de perdus ça a été une filière
clés à l'échelle mondiale sacrifié par
pur dogmatisme
c'est ça et aujourd'hui il s'agit aussi
de sortir du dogmatisme sortir du
dogmatisme c'est de dire il nous faut
une industrie forte sur le renouvelable
et il ne peut pas y avoir d'industrie
forte sur le renouvelable si évidemment
un ne la développe a pas en france les
50% en 2025 et 2025 et une date qui
n'est pas hors sol c'est la date qui
correspond à la pyramide des âges du
nucléaire
deux tiers des tranches nucléaires
françaises dépasseront les 40 ans entre
2020 et 2025
il s'agit donc bien avec le chiffre de
50% en 2025 de dire à peu près une
tranche sur deux sera prolongée a priori
de 20 ans à un coût de plus de 1
milliard la tranche
c'est dire qu'on aura de toute manière
pas les moyens de prolonger toutes les
tranches et on s'est quand à d'étranges
dangereuse donc on va passer un certain
temps dans les minutes qui viennent dans
les heures qui viennent sur ce chiffre
il est tout à fait raisonnable
il est tout à fait raisonnable il
correspond à une intégration européenne
il correspond à l'intérêt économique de
la france et correspond à la vétusté des
centrales françaises donc je pense qu'il
y aura beaucoup de dogmatique dans les
interventions mais effectivement c'est
50% en 2025 c'est tout simplement
rationnelle merci chantal jouanno à la
parole
merci merci madame la présidente alors
nous ne déposons pas un amendement qui
revient sur la question de la date ne
serait ce que parce qu'au sein de notre
propre au groupe qui a peut-être
beaucoup de discussions sur le sujet
delà de la date à laquelle il serait
souhaitable de réduire la part du
nucléaire à 50% dans une proposition de
résolution que nous avions déposé en
juin nous avions pris la date de 2040
par contre ce que vous que l'on vous
propose mais il ya un deuxième
amendement que je reviendrai juste juste
après ce que l'on vous propose c'est de
dire que cette baisse de la part du
nucléaire doit être bien évidemment
proportionnelle à l'augmentation de la
part des énergies renouvelables dans une
logique qui est d'assurer la
complémentarité entre les deux formes
d'énergie et pour répondre à plusieurs
interventions qui ont cité le modèle
allemand comme un contre modèle ou la
développement des énergies renouvelables
se ferait au profit en même temps des
énergies fossiles pour justement dire
que chez nous on veut de type d'énergie
décarbonnée une baisse du nucléaire mais
une augmentation du renouvelable
merci beaucoup le gouvernement un
amendement 893 madame la ministre
en effet sur un point tout à fait
sensible de notre de notre débat
donc par cet amendement je souhaite bien
évidemment rétablir l'horizon 2025 pour
cette réduction de la part du nucléaire
dans la production d'électricité de 115
% à 50 %
mais bien évidemment dans le souci comme
vous le disiez tout à l'heure monsieur
le sénateur de construire des
convergences et d'essayer d'arrêter
ensemble un modèle énergétique qui
puisse donner un signe clair en
particulier à nos entreprises puisque
c'est vrai que plus la représentation
nationale sera forte pour donner des
signaux clairs à nos entreprises plus
elles pourront investir avoir confiance
dans l'avenir calculés les retours sur
investissement calculé les durées
d'amortissement de leurs investissements
et construire ce nouveau modèle
énergétique tout en gagnant des parts de
marché à l'international
donc dans ce souci dans cette
préoccupation là le gouvernement fait
sien l'ensemble des critères qui ont été
travaillés et adoptée par votre
commission en particulier la façon dont
cette réduction de la part du nucléaire
va être accompagnée et surtout va être
conditionné donc il y a quatre éléments
qui ont été adoptées par votre
commission que je soutiens c'est pour ça
que je ne propose pas de les modifier
d'abord l'accompagnement de la montée en
puissance des énergies renouvelables
évidemment c'est une question majeure
puisque cette montée en puissance des
énergies renouvelables c'est bien ce qui
explique ce rééquilibrage du mix
énergétique qui va nous rendre plus
forts économiquement je vais essayer de
vous expliquer comment
deuxièmement le critère de
l'indépendance énergétique de la france
s'inquiétait en effet majeur
gouvernement soutient cette précision
troisièmement le maintien d'un prix de
l'électricité compétitif elle évidemment
une pas question d'en rabattre sur une
énergie qui serait compétitif pour la
remplacer par une énergie beaucoup plus
cher et quatrièmement dont il faut mais
oui mais c'est parce qu'il y aura au
cours des années aussi une montée en
puissance de la performance énergétique
du renouvelable et la baisse du coût
bien évidemment de la fabrication du
renouvelable est quatrième
évidemment sans conduire à une hausse
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
comme on le voit chez les pays voisins
ou l'allemagne par exemple qui à
renoncer au nucléaire est obligé de
rouvrir des mines de charbon et des
mines de lignite ça n'est pas bien
évidemment de notre modèle énergétique
en revanche je crois qu'il est important
de donner des signaux clairs c'est à
dire de fixer un cap
bien sûr que c'est un cas peu ambitieux
je le reconnais tout à fait 2025
mais est-ce qu'il n'est pas très
important pour nos grandes entreprises
énergétiques du secteur énergétique
d'avoir une visibilité claire est de
savoir ce que le pays veut en termes
d'objectifs je pense que c'est important
pour la décision d'investissement les
décisions économiques et financières
dans les entreprises
deuxièmement je pense vraiment que
organisé et fixer un cap sur ce mix
énergétique c'est un atout très
important pour nos entreprises et pour
notre filière nucléaire elle-même
je rappelle comme je les dis en réponse
à la discussion générale que nous avons
une magnifique filière industrielle avec
edf areva le commissariat à l'énergie
atomique et aux énergies alternatives et
nous avons vraiment la responsabilité et
d'ailleurs c'est leur souhait c'est leur
souhait c'est pour ça qu'elles ont
besoin de signaux clairs déchéance d'un
horizon de pourcentage pour qu'elle
puisse en effet prendre des décisions
stable et durable en termes
d'investissement et nous avons
absolument intérêts et elles aussi elles
sont en demande de règles claires pour
qu'elles investissent ce champ
industriel etc et ses marchés mondiaux
considérable sur les énergies
renouvelables
à titre d'exemple je vous rappelle que
des f vient de gagner la construction
d'une centrale photovoltaïque en chine
que c'est edf qui a construit la
centrale photovoltaïque qui se situer
sur le stade de la coupe du monde de
football au brésil et que
de plus en plus nos entreprises se
positionnent sur ces marchés les
énergies renouvelables et elles pourront
d'autant plus vendre leur technologie
nucléaire qu'elles seront en capacité
d'offrir aux grandes nations du monde
qui sont aujourd'hui en train de
s'engager puissamment dans un nouveau
mix énergétique qu'elles seront capables
elle même aussi d'offrir un mix
énergétique et nous souhaitons bien
évidemment et cela a été dit aussi sur
tous les bancs de cette assemblée que
nous puissions aider nos entreprises à
devenir d un champion mondial des
champions mondiaux sur le domaine
énergétique et qu'elle puisse surtout
sur les marchés internationaux se
présenter en équipe et pas les unes
contre les autres comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui c'est quand je doit arbitrer
sur les halls et les offres les appels
d'offres sur l'éolien offshore et que je
dois je dois choisir entre edf et gdf
d'un côté areva alstom de l'autre ça
fait quand même bizarre
et donc quand nos entreprises aussi sont
en compétition sur les marchés mondiaux
au lieu d'être unie de dudu ni de
rassembler leurs forces de mettre en
commun leur énergie au sens propre comme
au sens figuré
leur modèle de recherche et cetera elle
serait beaucoup plus forte sur les
marchés mondiaux
nous avons perdu un certain nombre de
marchés dans le domaine du nucléaire
abou dhabi par exemple sur le coréen qui
ont suivi centrale les etats unis sont
en train de se positionner à l'égard de
l'inde
je reviens de d'un double jeu participer
au sommet mondial sur le climat et le
premier ministre le nouveau premier
indien s'est engagé fortement dans son
mix énergétique puisqu'il va multiplier
par six l'énergie nucléaire et il va
construire et le programme énergétique
de l'inde
c'est de construire 100 gigawatts de
photovoltaïque et 100 villes
intelligentes
c'est à dire autonome en énergie
et donc les entreprises françaises elles
ont la démarche est considérable à
conquérir
à condition qu'elle soit forte sur
l'ensemble des énergies et nous sommes
le seul pays à pouvoir offrir un mix
énergétique vers le seul pays à l'heure
des entreprises qu'ils soient à la fois
positionné sur le nucléaire est
positionné sur le renouvelable et donc
nous devons encourager nos entreprises à
accompagner et à profiter de cette
transition énergétique et certainement
pas à leur dire que rien ne doit bouger
et que le modèle français c'est le toux
ou le quasi tout nucléaire parce que ça
va se retourner contre nos entreprises
et donc quand on pense bien faire mais
moi je respecte l'opinion des uns des
eaux je respecte a fait monsieur longuet
vos opinions en plus vous vous laissez
les exprimer avec respect c'est pas le
cas sur tous les bancs de cette
assemblée
je respecte votre vos opinions et je
pense que en disant cela en faisant cela
vous vous pensez défendre avec bonne foi
le la place la réputation de nos
entreprises sur le secteur du nucléaire
mais peut-être que justement on peut
défendre la réputation des entreprises
sur le secteur du nucléaire en les
poussant en avant aussi en les
encourageant à faire en sorte qu'elles
maîtrisent fortement l'ensemble des
technologies à la fin du nucléaire du
renouvelable et de la performance
énergétique
parce qu'aujourd'hui les grandes nations
qui font appel aux technologies
énergétiques pour engager leur mutation
énergétique et cela de façon accélérée
savent à toute allure aujourd'hui
l'évolution de l'evole l'évolution du de
la transition énergétique et ça va
s'accélérer
pascal approche de la conférence de
paris sur le climat
aujourd'hui tous les pays du monde
doivent présenter à l'organisation des
nations unies leur feuille de route sur
la transition énergétique
donc il va y avoir une compétition
mondiale industriel extrêmement forte et
je pense que le meilleur service à
rendre à nos grandes entreprises
énergéticienne c'est extrêmement clair
offensive ambitieux sur les perspectives
de rééquilibrage du mix énergétique et
c'est la raison pour laquelle tout en
intégrant parce que je pense que les
travaux de votre commission qui ont
énormément auditionné justement le les
entreprises et qui ont le souci votre
commission est le souci aussi d'être à
la fois crédible cohérente et rassembler
les critères qui peuvent permettre
d'éclairer les raisons pour lesquelles
lorsque l'on dit on passe de 75 à 50% ce
n'est pas une remise en cause du
nucléaire
au contraire c'est une façon de
conforter notre filière nucléaire parce
que c'est une façon aussi de lui donner
les moyens d'investir dans les nouvelles
technologies du renouvelable en rendant
ces investissements rentables en rendant
ses avis ses investissements
amortissable sur un délai raisonnable en
fixant un objectif clair parce que si
une entreprise n'a pas d'objectif clair
celles se dit la représentation
nationale ne sais pas si c'est la fin du
siècle la moitié du siècle 2025 2050
c'est très compliqué pour l'entreprise
après d'arrêter des stratégies
d'investissement des stratégies
d'amortissement des stratégies
industrielles des stratégies de conquête
de marché et c'est pourquoi il me semble
que nous devons à la fois accompagner
cette mutation la garantir i m des
conditions dont les quatre conditions
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure qui sont
issus de votre commission et en même
temps d'être clair sur les horizons et
sur les perspectives
sachant sachant que même si pour
certains je le comprends d'ailleurs ça
peut paraître ambitieux et rapproché il
y a dans le vote de cette loi aussi la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
c'est à dire la révision des objectifs
au fur et à mesure de la montée en
puissance mais si nous mêmes ne nous
mettons des freins ou si nous mêmes
avons l'air de douter dans la capacité
de nos entreprises à monter en puissance
sur le mix énergétique à conquérir les
technologies à investir dans la maîtrise
de l'offre de services et de l'offre
industrielle que l'ensemble des pays du
monde sont en train d'attendre à ce
moment là elles mêmes vont douter
d'elle-même
donc nous si nous sommes clairs sur nos
objectifs si nous sommes unis sur les
objectifs alors nos entreprises sont les
plus fortes au niveau mondial j'aurai
pour terminer dire que et je reprends de
cet exemple que j'évoquais hier c'est
qu'en revenant du sommet mondial des
énergies renouvelables à abou dhabi dans
un pays producteur de pétrole
ne vous y étiez de certains d'entre vous
y était c'est quand même fascinant de se
dire qu'un pays producteurs de pétrole
organise le sommet mondial des énergies
renouvelables c'est à dire prépare
l'après pétrole et ne nous resterions
figé sur le modèle énergétique d'hier
non ce sont ceux qui vont anticipé
raisonnablement de façon maîtrisée mais
de façon volontariste et de façon
confiante dans nos grands industriels
qui sont aujourd'hui bien positionné
mais qui se font aujourd'hui dépassée on
le voit dans les attributions des grands
marchés mondiaux que nous pourrons leur
redonner confiance en eux et que nous
pourront accompagner cette transition
énergétique en créant le plus possible
d'emplois et de plus values industrielle
dans notre pays merci madame la ministre
madame jouanno le 622 rectifier oui
merci madame la présidente
dans la nouvelle rédaction de l'alinéa
28 il a été introduit une disposition
indiquant que la réduction de la part du
nucléaire là son lasso fermeture des
centrales intervenez en fait sous deux
initiatives la première c'est
l'application duel 593 23 du code de
l'environnement et la deuxième c'est la
demande de l'exploitant le elle 593 23
c'est du bon sens c'est à dire c'est la
fermeture d'une centrale à la demande de
l'asn en cas de risques graves
c'est un cas je l'espère normalement
très exceptionnel
la deuxième
la deuxième le deuxième facteur de
fermeture serait donc la demande de
l'exploitant
il me semble extrêmement mal venue que
dans une loi ou logiquement on est en
train d'expliquer que c'est le politique
que ce sont les pouvoirs publics qui
détermine qui décident de l'avenir du
mix énergétique
on renvoie à la simple demande d'un
exploitant l'opportunité de faire
évoluer ou non se mixer négliger
énergétique
donc nous avons déposé un amendement ou
nous supprimons justement ces deux
nouvelles dispositions merci beaucoup
le 194 rectifié bis gérard longuet oui
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues mon excellent
collègue qui a défendu avec verve talent
chaleur l'idée que je souhaitais
défendre qui est que le nucléaire n'a
simplement aucune raison d'être victime
d'un choix idéologique que ses
performances ne ne justifie en rien
performance du nucléaire vous les
connaissez et je voudrais rentrer un peu
plus en profondeur dans le choix que
vous faites
s'agit-il de plafonner à 50% la
production d'énergie ou les capacités de
production il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui
le nucléaire ne représente que 49% des
capacités de production électrique de
notre pays
le thermique représente en gros 25%
l'hydraulique et le renouvelable le
solde jeu ma conviction est que nous
n'avons pas à mettre en cause cette
capacité et que nous devons nous garder
en particulier la possibilité d'un d'une
énergie nucléaire vivant pour notre
marché national et pour le marché
international
là où je suis madame le ministre en
désaccord total avec votre démonstration
c'est que si nous voulons une filière
nucléaire offensive au plan mondial et
vous avez cité par exemple l'inde
qui souhaitent s'équiper d'une vingtaine
de centrales nucléaires nous ne pourrons
le faire que si nous avons un marché
national vivant si ce marché national
vivant du nucléaire est soumis à un
risque politique majeur
il n'y a simplement aucune chance que
les industries des industriels
fusse-t-il public continue d'investir
pour le renouveau de ses produits
ils ne pourront pas investir non plus
sur la diversification de l'offre que
nous avions évoqué avec notre collègue
guillaume et qui est certainement une
des réponses le nucléaire est vu en
france à travers des unités importante
il y aura certainement une demande pour
laquelle nous sommes parfaitement
compétent et capable sur des unités plus
petites
il y a qu une seule règle c'est le bon
sens économique
si vous laissez la liberté économique
chère madame cher collègue lienemann les
investisseurs suivront si vous soumettez
la décision économique aux risques
politiques les investissent les
investisseurs iront ailleurs
et donc en imposant une barrière
politique à la vie du nucléaire vous
découragez totalement ce secteur
industriel pour les arguments liés à
l'économie décarbonée je reprends ce
qu'a dit mon collègue requis et dirai
simplement
arrêtons de politiser la vie quotidienne
alors que le bon sens économique existe
et pourquoi aurions-nous raison contre
tout le monde